Gwen Stefani and Blake Shelton seem to  be madly in love I just like being with  her such good chemistry  the cute couple had their love on full  display Friday packing on major PDA  outside Joan's on third cafe in Studio  City  Botox caught the country crooner and pop  singer sharing a sweet smooch on the  patio after their low-key lunch date and  the two lovebirds appeared smitten with  each other  paying no mind to on lookers during  their embrace smiling from ear to ear  Gwen sported sunglasses a camouflage  coat and jeans while Blake kept things  cool and casual in a plaid shirt and cap  I was only trying to impress win-win and  Blake sure know how to make our hearts  melt  you